on the one-year anniversary of President
Trump selection the left loses its mind
even more than usual the Republicans are
still struggling to pass tax cuts and I
want to talk about why bad things happen
to good people I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show so what prompted me
to think why bad things happen to people
is I'm sick as a dog and I'm a good
person
why God why but really I'm I am kind of
sick so bear with me today even though
my voice is lower and more manly than
usual I appreciate you sticking with me
so before we jump into the leftist going
absolutely insane yesterday on the
one-year anniversary of President Trump
winning the presidency first don't say
thank you to our sponsors over a wing so
could you use a drink right now I sure
could
that's why wink is great okay so wink
makes it really easy for you to get the
best wines and not just the best wines
the ones that are tailored to your
palate you got to go over to somebody's
house for dinner you don't know what
wine to bring you don't want to bring a
bottle of Manischewitz because you don't
want to look like an idiot and so you
need a wine that goes with their meal
well you go on winked calm you go to try
blink calm slash been try wink winc calm
slash man and you take their survey you
fill out their palate profile quiz and
they will tell you what sort of wine
goes with your palate what sort of wine
goes with your meal discover great wine
today at try wink comm slash Ben and you
got 20 bucks off your first shipment
again that's t ry winc comm slash Ben
for $20 off your first shipment try wink
comm slash Ben it's the wine is really
terrific it's why everyone around here
is terrible at their jobs they're drunk
all the time from link wine but it is
true that the the wine itself is really
good and less expensive then you'll have
then then you'll get at the local liquor
store it's better and again they'll tell
you what's the best wine for you try
wink calm slash Ben for $20 off plus
they'll know that we sent you okay so I
could not help but laugh despites my
personal discomfort I could not help but
laugh yesterday hysterically as a bunch
of people on the Left went out into the
streets of New York and decided to
aimlessly scream at the sky no I am not
kidding it was the one-year anniversary
of President Trump winning if you want
to see my reaction to President Trump
winning all you have to do is go to
youtube and google shapiro laughing for
two minutes because that's exactly what
happened we covered it on election night
and Bill Whittle friend of ours he said
President Trump and it struck me for
just a moment
how
dick you listen hilarious that is and
also that Hillary had lost and I just
started laughing and I couldn't stop
laughing for a fully two minutes he's
pretty great but that is not how
everyone reacted a bunch of folks on the
Left were heartbroken they're still
heartbroken and they've lost their minds
so yesterday in New York City people
gathered to scream at the sky okay I
know these are probably the same people
who say thoughts and prayers are useless
right same people who stays thought you
shouldn't say thoughts and prayers when
something bad happens now they're
gathering to scream at a sky where there
is no God presumably and and I could not
help but laugh hysterically at this
[Music]
a lady trying out for the met opera but
I I do I do love it you're gonna get
together and scream at the sky yeah
that's that's gonna win that's gonna
that's gonna make you guys win now it is
true that the anger of the left is gonna
drive down to the polls more often I
mean that that's sort of what you saw in
Virginia but if they think that this is
an attractive feature then they're going
to win elections because they scream at
the sky then I think not but for the
left they believe that their anger is
its own justification so there are a
couple of columns that I want to talk
about today that demonstrate just how
far go on the left is when it comes to
policy and politics now it is possible
the Republicans can be bad enough with
this to blow whatever advantages they
have it seems like that's what they're
in the business of doing we'll talk
about what they're doing with their tax
plan in just a second and we'll also
talk about President Trump in just a
second and the divides inside the
conservative movement but on the Left
they've completely lost their minds and
so they feel that the only path back to
power is twofold one they have to be as
angry as possible and two they have to
reimburse identity politics
okay these are precisely the things that
brought them Trump is their anger and
their identity politics that caused the
backlash that brought President Trump so
maybe there's a backlash to the backlash
that's quite possible right there was a
backlash to the left identity politics
and rage and that was brought about in
the form of the Tea Party and President
Trump was the culmination of that it is
also possible that there's a backlash to
that backlash that's building right now
whatever it is it ain't good for the
country two columns in particular I want
to talk about today both from the
horrific New York Times so the New York
Times is Andrew Clavin calls at a former
newspaper there op-ed page is filled
with joy the last 48 hours my personal
favorite column is from a woman named
Lindy West who writes on feminism in
popular culture which already makes you
want to run through a wall so it's so
hard that it leaves a u-shaped hole in
the wall like a cartoon but here is what
she says in the pages of the New York
Times and it's called brave enough to be
angry really this is what it's called
brave enough to be angry which is like I
didn't realize it takes bravery to be
pissed I really didn't realize this I
like when you just take two emotions how
about angry enough to be brave how about
sad enough to be happy
maybe when she announced that in any
case here's what here's what the column
says and it's pretty amazing it says
last month and Access Hollywood
correspondent asked the actress Uma
Thurman's to comment on abuse of power
in Hollywood
presumably in light of the sexual
assault allegations against the producer
Harvey Weinstein speaking slowly and
deliberately
through gritted teeth Thurmond responded
quote I don't have a tidy soundbite for
you because I've learned I am NOT a
child and I've learned that when I've
spoken in anger I usually regret the way
I express myself so I've been waiting to
feel less angry when I'm ready I'll say
what I have to say Thurmond is seething
like we all have been seething in our
various states of breaking open or as
Thurmond chooses waiting we are seething
at how long we've been ignored seething
for the ones who are told long ago who
are punished long ago for telling the
truth seething for being told all our
lives we have no right to seethe has
this woman never met a woman has she met
like a girl that girls get angry my wife
gets mad my mom gets mad my sisters get
mad my three-year-old daughter
definitely gets mad I was unaware that
women are not allowed to be angry women
are definitely out allowed be it doesn't
mean that they're they're attractive
when they're angry because men aren't
attractive when they're angry they're in
fact people generally are not
particularly attractive when they're
angry but you're seething and how long
you've been ignored lady are writing in
the pages of the New York Times being
ignored okay so she continues along
these lines Thurman's rage is palpable
yet contain conveying not just the
tempestuous depths of hashtag me to God
the writing is so bad I don't know who
edits over the New York Times they
should be fired immediately but a
profound understanding of the ways that
female anglers received and weaponized
against women and now she's gonna go
explain all the ways that women's anger
is not taken seriously but does she cite
sexual assault or rape like women who
have claimed they were raped or sexual
assaulted and are angry about it and
people told them to sit down and shut up
no she doesn't cite any of that because
that's never happened okay no one says
to women who say they were raped why are
you so mad you mad bro no one says that
to a woman who is raped you can't name
anyone who says that to a woman who is
raped so what are the examples of female
anger we've been ignoring get ready for
this from Lindy West again this is just
indicative of the left's belief that
anger is its own justification quote in
the past few months alone we've seen
Carmen you lean crews mayor of San Juan
Puerto Rico pilloried by the far right
for criticizing Donald Trump's anemic
response to Hurricane Maria we are dying
here Cruz told the news media aya mad as
hell and the Florida congresswoman
Frederica Wilson deluged with abuse
after she characterized Trump's call to
a military Widow
Myesha Johnson as insensitive as an
insult both Cruz and Wilson were
directly targeted by the president's on
Twitter that incessantly memed and
regurgitated and read i justed and
reamed by his obedience on wide
it's like the Huns out there okay first
of all the cases she just cited are not
cases of sexual assault or abuse in one
the mayor of San Juan went out there and
had shirts printed that said we are
dying so she could go on national
television and rip into Trump no one
would have paid attention to her
otherwise and Frederica Wilson went out
there and talked out of school about a
conversation that really was between a
military widow and the presidents of the
United States and apparently you know
may have misinterpreted Trump's comments
so all of this is we were saying why are
these women angry not because they were
raped or sexually abused but because
they were getting political we were more
angry at what they were doing than their
anger and but the examples continue she
gives the example of Julie Brisbane
who's a government contractor who
supposedly lost her job after a photo of
her flipping off the presidential
motorcade went viral
she wasn't fired because she flipped off
the motorcade she was fired because she
made that her profile photo on Facebook
and Twitter and works for a government
contractor that's why she was fired and
then here's some other examples of women
who have been disrespected and their
anger ignored and just female identity
politics at its best then if women are
angry we don't have to ask why they're
angry or if the anger is justified we
just have to get out of their way and
honor their anger I don't own her
anyone's anger really I don't think it's
something to be honored and not to quote
Clavin too much today but and Clavin I
used the phrase I really like he says
anger is the devil's cocaine and I think
that's pretty much correct okay here
here's what it actually is so here the
other examples a female anger that we
have been ignoring Solange yes really so
launched Knowles okay we weren't
ignoring her anger she's beaten the crap
out of jay-z in an elevator I mean
that's that's what was happening that
Britney Spears
I don't recall when we were angry at her
anger I just remember her getting like
wildly out of control and attempting to
beat a beat on a paparazzi Shanaya
O'Connor
the Dixie Chicks Rosie O'Donnell what
does any of this have to do a sexual
assault or us disrespecting their anger
okay then it says we don't even have to
be angry to be called angry accusations
of being an angry black woman chased
Michelle Obama throughout her tenure at
the White House well I mean to be fair
in 2008 she did say that she was not
proud of the country until it nominated
her husband that seems kind of angry to
me and if you opportunity for speeches
in 2008 they were kind of angry later
she became behind of a model first lady
but at the beginning she had a very
different persona was very much like
Hillary Clinton in her early years in
the White House and then shifting
her later years to be sort of more soft
and cuddly and then she finishes the
decades-long smearing of Hillary Clinton
as an unhinged shrew culminated one year
ago when despite maintaining a
preternatural calm throughout the most
brutal campaign in living memory she
lost the election to masculinities
apoplectic ed okay so the the smearing
of Hillary Clinton is an unhinged shrew
is not really a smearing she's an
unhinged shrew okay like they're they're
they're been actual reports of Hillary
Clinton throwing lamps at her husband
okay Hillary Clinton apparently was not
nice to secret service members Hillary
Clinton went out and complained about a
vast right-wing conspiracy when her
husband committed perjury well well you
know sexually harassing the help Hillary
Clinton in this campaign there's tape of
her shouting into camera why am I not up
by 50 points we all remember when she
did a speech calling half the population
deplorable
okay Hillary Clinton is not a model of
preternatural calm you have to be crazy
to think this then she says this is my
favorite line like every other feminist
with a public platform and perpetually
cast as a disapproving scold but what's
the alternative to approve I do not
approve right because you're a
disapproving skull I mean like I like is
that the definition you're scolding me
and you're disapproving like what am I
missing here and then she says not only
on women expected to whether sexual
violence intimate partner violence
workplace discrimination institutional
subordination the expectation of free
domestic labor the blame for our own
victimization and all the subtler
invisible cuts that undermine us daily
we are not even allowed to be angry
about it close your eyes and think of
America rights like America raping you
right I'm gonna explain a little more on
how stupid this is one of the worst
comments I've ever had in New York Times
and then it was rivaled this morning by
one from our good friend I believes
Charles blow writing this the aptly
named Charles blow writing at the New
York Times here is but before we get to
any of that first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Birch gold
so right now if you're looking the stock
market and thinking maybe there's a bit
of a bubble maybe it's a little
overvalued don't get the real estate
market thinking the same thing if you're
hedging against the possibility of a
downturn you need to have some money in
precious metals and people I trust for
that out of the folks at Birch gold
group they saw physical precious metals
for your own possession they will ship
metals directly to your front door they
have a long-standing track record of
success with thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold group now to
request a free information kit on
physical precious metals and they have a
comprehensive 16 page get
tell you everything you need to know
about protecting your savings and again
moving your IRA or 401k out of stocks
and into precious metals if that's
something you want to do to get that
no-cost no-obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com
slash Ben use the slash man so they know
that we set you okay so there's a Lindy
West again this is endemic to the
feminists left this belief that anger is
the is the driving force and they have a
reason to be angry
she says the women are expected to
whether sexual violence who expects
women's whether sexual violence like
really who is it that says yeah when
they're getting great big deal the only
person I can think of is somebody like
maybe gates at least the the columnist
who came out in defense of Kevin Spacey
but who is saying that intimate violent
the intimate partner violence is okay or
workplace discrimination the expectation
of free domestic labor on even what that
means like I expect my mother I expect
my wife to actually help with the chores
um
I help with the chores too like then
this is part of being an adult like I
understand Lindy West doesn't want to
wash her underwear but stuff like that
is just insane and finally she says we
are expected to agree and we comply with
the paternal admonition that it is
irresponsible and hyper emotional to
request one female president after two
hundred forty one years of male ones
because that would be tokenism
anti-democratic and dangerous as though
generations of white male politicians
haven't proven themselves utterly
disinterested and caring for the needs
of communities to which they do not
belong okay so now she's saying that
we're a sexist if we don't think that
you should elect a woman based on her
sex which is sexist by the way and then
she says white men's monopolistic death
grip on power in America doesn't belong
the kind of identity politics they claim
to abhor as a competent qualified women
are so thin on the ground that even
concerted since you're a large-scale
search form to be a long shot and any
resulting candidate a compromised
no we just in killer was a crappy
candidate that was perfectly willing to
vote for you know Elizabeth Dole
you know I'd be perfectly willing to
vote for Nikki Haley are you perfectly
willing to vote for a bevy of women but
not Hillary Clinton so I love this this
is the very end of her column she says I
did not call myself a feminist until I
was nearly twenty years old my world had
taught me that feminists were ugly and
ridiculous well actually your column is
basically teaching the world that
feminists are ugly and ridiculous he
said I did not want to be ugly and
ridiculous fail I wanted to be cool and
desired by men even as a teenager by the
way I'm not speaking physical ugliness
oh talk about an ugly attitude I want to
be cool and desired by men because even
as a teenager I knew him
the pandering for male approval was a
woman's most effective currency it was
my best shot at success or least safety
and I wasn't sophisticated enough to see
the success and safety bestowed
conditionally aren't success and safety
at all what she's saying here is that I
should be as much of a turd as I
possibly want to be and everyone should
make way for me well maybe the reason
that you're off-putting is because
you're off-putting is that possible is
it possible the reason that you haven't
been as successful as you want to be is
not because of sexism it's cuz you're a
nasty shrew okay because this this
column reads like a nasty shrew can you
call yourself a disapproving scold
that's what this column is you imply
that all white men are out to harm women
you imply that all conservatives don't
care about women you implied that we are
using the superstructure of power in
order to keep you down I don't care
about keeping Lindy West even know who
Lindy West is I don't spend my time
thinking about Lindy West except when
she writes in the pages of the New York
Times and accuses people like me of
being sexist for no reason and then
suggest I want to tamp down her anger
listen lending because angries you want
to be I hope you're angrier I hope you
continue to grow angrier because then
the angrier you are and the louder you
yell the more off-putting you are and
the more people see your agenda for what
it is which is baseless rage you're
looking the freest country in the
history of the world for women by far
they are sitting here complaining
they're being somehow downtrodden by men
in the pages of the New York Times this
she says it took me two decades to
become brave enough to be angry feminism
is the collective manifestation of
female anger
well if that's what it is no wonder so
many people are rejecting it there's any
movement that is a culmination of
collective anger is not gonna be a good
movement by the way I've said that about
movements both left and right I think
that's what the alt-right is based on is
based on you know unrooted on evidence
to anger okay so that is that is one
perspective that the left is taking a
year after Trump they're doubling down
on the anger but that's not the only way
they're doubling down so Charles blow as
I say has a piece of the New York Times
in which he says it's very important for
the left to reimburse identity politics
he says he's very happy about what
happened in Virginia he's suggesting
that what happened in Virginia is a
resuscitation of the Obama coalition now
this is factually not true what happened
in Virginia is a lot of college-educated
white people went out and voted against
Donald Trump in Northern Virginia
particularly okay so and Gillespie
actually won more of the black vote in
Virginia than Donald Trump won and
Gillespie one less of the
college-educated white vote in Virginia
than Donald Trump won
okay so the fact is that when Charles
blow says that identity politics is the
identity politics coalition of the left
you know blacks and Hispanics and gays
and young people that this coalition is
what's gonna drive the left to victory
he's ignoring the fact that's not
actually what drove them to victory in
Virginia widespread disapproval from the
Republican Party and Trump drove them to
victory in Virginia but here's what blow
has to say he says Tuesday night's
election results were a major shot in
the arm for the anti Donald Trump
resistance and a major slap in the face
for all the Democrats who caterwauls
last November about how the party had
focused too much on courting women and
minorities and ignored an angry white
med okay well Democrats weren't just
caterwauling last November about that
they should have been caterwauling for
years Obama lost the house he lost the
Senate he lost the governor's houses he
lost state legislators across the
country and he did that on the basis of
identity politics the reason that they
won in Virginia was not because of
identity politics the reason they won in
Virginia was actually because there was
a lot of resistance to Trump personally
that crossed a lot of these boundaries
but according to blow it's because of
identity politics
so he says objecting to identity
politics is just a guise for objecting
to politics for and about people who are
not white so when I say I don't like
identity politics of white people or now
and white people when I say that we
shouldn't have the politics of
solidarity based on race apparently I'm
still standing up for white people this
is basically the argument you hear very
frequently on college campuses with
regards to so-called white privilege
right that if you refuse to acknowledge
white privilege and you say instead
people should be judged as individuals
this is you reinforcing white privilege
after all because the standards of
society are standards that benefit white
people so below is saying the same thing
he's saying if you say no identity
politics well you're really saying is
only identity politics for white people
that's asinine but here's what he says
he says he's quoting feminist author
Laurie Penney in salon which is always a
good hit something crap he's about to
happen cuz all politics are identity
politics especially the politics of the
far-right
they're about this idea of white
identity this idea of male identity that
feels so under attack at the moment when
people attack identity politics they are
attacking politics that prioritizes or
even includes women people of color
queer people no that's not right when I
tack identity politics I'm suggesting
that there are ideas that ought to unite
us beyond the boundaries of our group
identity and that holds true for white
people and black people that holds true
for Hispanic people and Jewish people I
think
nakai identity is meaningless but
Charles blow things that if I say that
that's just me upholding the white
privilege and so what we really need to
do if you're Democrats is double down on
the intersectionality politics he says
that whole conversation about how we
must reject identity politics left a
lasting bad taste in my mouth he's such
a terrible writer I will confess that
I'm still smarting over the implication
of those conversations in part because
as a black man in America I have seen
the corpse flower that can grow from
that seed so if you reject identity
politics apparently order her black
people he says I'm always reminded of
when the Republican Party abandoned
black people who have been nothing but
loyal to them to pursue the very racist
who hated black people it was called the
Southern Strategy and it wasn't that
long ago and black people who have never
forgotten that betrayal now vote
overwhelmingly Democratic they're about
seven false statements in this
particular paragraph a false statement
number one black people had started to
vote for Democrats in large numbers by
the 1930s because of FDR number two the
idea that the Republicans pursued the
so-called Southern Strategy and this is
what won them the south is just not true
the Republican Party only dominated the
south in the 1990s and remained all
Democratic areas in Congress
particularly throughout the 70s 60s and
80s it was only the 90s Republicans
started to make inroads in other words
young people in the south moved
Republican because industry had coming
into the south not because of race
issues not because of race issues if
race issues played a role it was a
pretty minor one I have a full thing two
bunking this here's a full video I've
done two bunking this Hill didn't be
releasing pretty soon about the southern
strip the so-called Southern Strategy
also worth noting Democrats were
pandering along racial lines at the time
George Wallace in 1968 was running as a
Democrat right and then he moved
independent it was Democrats were
standing in the doorways of schools to
prevent integration it was not
Republicans doing that and the idea that
in the 70s the party switched is just
not true either
because if that were true you would
expect to see all these Democratic
politicians in the south turn Republican
none of them did except Strom Thurmond
there are literally dozens and dozens
and dozens of governors and Senators
they all remain Democrats so this is
just not true then he says the fact that
Democratic strategists were even
actively thinking of courting voters who
turned a blind eye to or actively
cheered from spiggott Rhee underscored
for me the fact that for this party
principles can be situational so in
other words he's saying abandoned white
voters who voted for Trump they're all
racist he says I wrote in January the
enlightenment must never bow to the
Inquisition and I hope
that position in other words the
identity politics of black folks and
Hispanic folks is better than the
identity politics of white folks and so
the Democratic Party should turn away
from the white vote
he says for me there is no middle if you
are supporting Donald Trump you're
supporting Trump ISM and all that goes
with it that means you are supporting a
modus operandi that attacks people of
color on every term but keeps white
supremacists safe you're supporting
Trump's demeaning of women who are
supporting his bullying you are
supporting his corruption you're
supporting his pathological lying you
want to know how Democrats could blow it
in 2018 by listening to Charles blow
really because what he's suggesting is
that every Trump voter is a deplorable
every single one right they didn't vote
for Trump as the lesser of two evils
they didn't vote for Trump because they
wanted some policy would they vote for
him because they all silently approve of
all of the bad things that Trump does I
don't think that's true I don't think
that's correct
and I think if Democrats want to ignore
the 63 million people who voted for
Donald Trump in this last election cycle
by writing them off
good luck winning elections good luck
winning elections he finishes by saying
planes the identity politics of Trump
loving angry white men a clear
expression of white supremacist
patriarchy isn't a panacea panacea it's
not even prudent and conversing and
conversely inclusive identity politics
isn't to poison white supremacy and the
panic induced when that supremacy is
threatened is the poison so he says
inclusive identity politics is good
meaning identity politics not for white
people but for everyone else that's good
why density politics is bad now notice
how the term anger is used here I'm
gonna explain in just a second how the
term anger has morphed between these two
columns that I've just read you and why
it's demonstrative of the fact that for
the Democrats everything is a tool
everything is a means toward toward
victory but they're actually
undercutting their own agenda but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Beachbody on demand so next week
I will be traveling and when I travel
and I'm in my hotel I do not typically
go to the gym instead I stay in the room
and I use Beachbody on demand they have
tons of courses they have tons of
nutritional nutritional recipes great
ways for you to get in shape
Beachbody on demand is an online fitness
streaming service that gives you
unlimited access to a wide variety of
highly effective world-class workout
stuff you've heard of piyo 21 day fix
p90x insanity right they've got all of
these things that you can stream live
and then I just started you know I've
been doing p90x and when I'm on the road
it's a really great workout that fills
in the gaps
especially for when I'm not home and
they have over a hundred recipe videos
where you can learn how to prep your
meals and click kid or vegan friendly
meals that it's called fixates that's
the name of the show you know again this
is it's the best way to to work out
whether you're at home or on the road I
use it frequently when I'm on the road
myself my listeners can claim a free
trial membership just text Shapiro two
three one three one three one text
Shapiro two thirty one thirty one thirty
one and get full access to the entire
platform for free and try it out against
B again Beachbody on demand is the best
way to get in shape and stay in shape
Shapiro texted to thirty one thirty one
thirty one and get full access to the
entire platform for free they're already
over a million people who are who are
members of the service Beachbody on
demand all the things that you've always
wanted to try up and haven't had a
chance to yet Shapiro text it to thirty
one thirty one thirty one
okay so Charles blows final comment here
that you shouldn't play to the a density
politics of angry white men you know the
this is this is why you see the
reactionary politics happening from both
sides on the one side you see Charles
blow saying black people have a right to
be angry Hispanic people have a right to
be angry of Lindy West females have a
right to be angry and anyone who denies
the right to be angry anyone who even
suggests that maybe the anger isn't
justified those are all the bad guys and
then they turn around and say you know
the real angry people are they're the
people on the right they're all the
white people the angry white people and
then you know what that does a lot of
angry people on the right they say yeah
you know what screw it as long as we're
gonna play this game as long as we're
gonna play this game then we'll play
this game this is how you end up with
reactionary politics that makes the
entire country worse regardless of who
wins elections I don't think this will
help Democrats win elections by the way
I don't think screaming at the sky I
don't think being angry at the
patriarchy I don't think me angry at the
Constitution or being angry at the the
vast bulk of Americans who happened to
be white by the way it's sixty nine
seventy percent of Americans are still
white you know that I do not think this
is more politics by the Democrats but
this is what they're going for anyway
and meanwhile the Democrats are
attacking each other so despite their
victories in Virginia there are still
some systemic obstacles Democrats have
to overcome including the fact that a
lot of the districts they won the other
night our districts that were Hillary
districts to begin with they're gonna
have to flip a few Trump districts in
order for them to actually take the
house so I would say right now that if
you have to bet you bet on the Democrats
taking the house but it's not in it's
not an easy bet it's it's it's a bit of
a
it's a bit of a stretch bed the
Democrats are attacking each other
however Bernie Sanders and Donna Brazile
are going full-on full-bore against
Hillary Clinton this is what the
Democrats have to do but there are a lot
of Democrats are pushing back against it
here is Sanders praising Donna Brazile
former head of the DNC
who has been ripping Hillary up and down
look Donna Brazile showed an enormous
amount of courage in describing the
truth as she saw it when she came into
the leadership of the DNC I don't think
there's any sane human being who doesn't
believe that my campaign was taking on
the entire establishment including the
DNC but Anderson to be very honest with
you my job our job is to go forward is
to do everything we can to defeat this
right-wing agenda of the Republican
Party in the Trump administration not to
look backwards he's one of the things I
think that's happening inside the
Democratic Party aside from the the
internecine battles I think that you
actually have a battle of cults I think
of a battle of cults Brazil said it
herself she said that the Clinton
campaign was basically like the cults
but I think it's more than that right
here's Donna Brazile saying that last
night it was a cult I felt like it was a
cult you could not penetrate them I mean
I look you can I'm a grassroot organizer
I know I know street politics better I
know sweet politics I know how to touch
people where they live work play and
pray but I cannot do it I cannot help a
candidate Joe if I don't have the
resources if I cannot spend the
resources that the party is raising okay
so she was describing the Clinton
campaign as a cult there's also the
Bernie Sanders cult and then they're
still the Barack Obama called so Charles
blows a member of the Obama cult right
Lindy West's member of the Hillary cult
and Bernie Sanders is a member of Bernie
Sanders called so all of these various
groups are battling with each other for
supremacy inside the Democratic Party
the only thing that unites them is
opposition to President Trump which is
why President Trump needs to do a better
job because you can unify under the
banner of opposing something like
President Trump but these cults are
exactly what have led the Democratic
Party to its own demise right well it's
created this is the Democratic Party let
Obama have his way with the DMC he ran
up huge debts he killed the party down
ballot and so they lost seats all across
the country then
they turned over the party to the cult
of Hillary who proceeded to destroy the
party even further or actually helped
shrug them up financially but she lost
them the presidency to the worst
Republican presidential candidate of my
lifetime President Trump and now the
Bernie Sanders cult is trying to take
over and they're gonna throw out the
non-believers these cult fights are not
good for parties the reason that I bring
this up is because I think that on the
right there's a tendency to get into
cult politics too and this is something
that I really have objected to for a
couple of years now I have always said
the point of politicians is not to
worship them they are people in a job
with a job to do if they're not doing
the job you criticize them if they are
doing the job you praise them I've said
this before the presidency is a is a
glorified DMV job being the president
means that you have a job a
constitutional oriented duty you're
supposed to fulfill those obligations
that's all we're not supposed to worship
you we're not supposed to pretend you're
some great godlike figure we're not
supposed to say that everything you do
is right but there's a tendency on on
all sides I think to fall into this
cult-like behavior and if Republicans
imitate the cult-like behavior of
Democrats toward Obama or toward Hillary
or towards Sanders they're gonna pay the
exact same price you're seeing that
happen with with President Trump that
there's a feeling inside Republican
halls of power that if you ever
criticize Trump or if you don't praise
him sufficiently even if you keep your
mouth shut on Trump then somehow you're
undermining the the great Idol that is
Trump and so you're seeing figures like
Paul Ryan feeling the necessity to go
out there and pay lip service to Trump
even when it may not be particularly
beneficial to do so so here's Paul Ryan
who's trying to pass a tax cut into law
right now we'll talk about that tax cut
and why it's a problem in just a second
but here's here's Ryan saying that the
Bush era is over we're now living in
Trump world do you have to make a
choices Republicans either you're gonna
side with President Bush in his policies
43 of more free trade and and maybe some
type of immigration compromise what do
you have to go with Donald Trump is it
gonna be a choice for Republicans Bush
or Trump we already made that choice
we're with Trump we already made that
choice that's that's a choice we made at
the beginning of the year that's a
choice he made during the campaign which
is we merged our agendas we ran on a
joint agenda with Donald Trump we got
together with Donald Trump when he was
president elect Trump and walked through
what is
we want to accomplish here's why this is
not useful this idea that we chose
between Bush and trumpet no you didn't
okay you're there to implement a set of
policy positions you have to choose
Trump you have to choose Bush you can
think both of them are crappy right you
can do all of these things but what you
do have to do is have an agenda as I say
the cult-like politics of the Democrats
with regards to Barack Obama really hurt
them down ballot the cult-like politics
with Hillary really hurt them call it
like politics with regard to Trump will
hurt them too because if you are if you
are treating a president like he's a
cult leader then you are going to ignore
warning signs that would allow you to
pull the car away from the ditch right
typically if you're gonna define a cult
typically the way the sort of
traditional way to define a cult is that
it has three features its exclusive its
secretive its authoritarian so exclusive
means that you're the only one with the
truth everyone who doesn't have the
truth is is sort of damned to hell right
and that's there's certainly this aspect
here right this is what Trump said about
out of gillespie basically Trump said to
Gillespie I'm the way the truth in life
if you don't follow me you got nothing I
say didn't embrace me strong enough and
that's why you lost secretive means
there's some sort of secret to it like
everyone inside the Trump group you know
people who are ardently program I'm not
talking about everyone who voted for
Trump of course I'm talking about people
like Bill Mitchell right people who
worship the ground Trump walks on for
those people there is a secret decoder
ring where everything Trump does is
genius
and finally authoritarianism this is
this sort of unquestioning obedience of
the leader when you do this with a party
leader you end up ignoring bad signs and
you ends up getting into useless Wars
now Steve Bannon is one of the the chief
architects of this sort of cult of Trump
and Bannon is going around leading Wars
against members of his own party who are
trying to pass from so Genda right now
because it's more important to uphold
the glory of the leader than it is to
actually pass legislation that Trump
says he wants to pass here is Trump
saying that Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader ought to resign again
I'm not a Mitch McConnell fan I've been
bashing McConnell for years but the idea
that McConnell has to resign because of
what exactly Bannon can't say he just
wants the scalps that he can go back to
Trump and saying listen I got a scallop
attention I'm to the point I think Mitch
McConnell to really bring unity to the
Republican Party and get things done I
think Mitch McConnell ought to tender
his resignation what he ought to do is
offer to resign as soon as taxes are
done we can't do in the middle of taxes
but I think Mitch McConnell tomorrow
should
tender his resignation said hey after we
get taxes done I will step aside and
we'll have a revote on majority leader
because I got to tell you there needs to
be a sense of urgency in the Senate you
know over the last about week that you
know they're now gonna work six days a
week they're talking about cancelling
Thanksgiving they passed the budget
they're starting to move on federal
judges but that's all because quite
frankly we put the spotlight on Mitch
McConnell and said that this guy is just
not supporting the president okay that
of course is utterly untrue okay it's
not that Steve Bannon put the spotlight
on McConnell everybody who's been
putting pressure on McConnell for years
but what this comes down to is does
Trump one his agenda passed or does he
not want him want his agenda passed or
is it all just posturing if it's all
just posturing that's very Obama it's an
Obama way to govern right and it's an
Obama way to destroy your own party
further down the ballot okay I want to
talk about some things I like things I
hate in the big idea today but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsor is
over at thrive market so thrive market
is an online grocer with a mission to
make healthy living affordable and
accessible to everyone for me you know
it's very difficult sometimes to get
grid a good organic kosher product well
kosher products are actually at places
like thrive market they are basically a
you know here's the reality you can get
what you want from thrive market that
you normally have to go to Whole Foods
for right from into Whole Foods Whole
Foods is much more expensive in many
cases you have to go there you have to
deal with all the the jackasses the
green jackasses in their in their
unicorn fart powered Priuses bothering
you in the parking lot thrive you don't
have to do that right you just go online
and you get all of your premium non-gmo
organic products and wholesale prices
delivered directly to your door right
with one click of a button you can sort
all of their catalog by 90 values if I
just want kosher products I just say
give me kosher products they'll show me
all the kosher product if I just want
vegan products they can do that as well
it is hyper curated so instead of having
to choose between 15 different almond
butters at the local health store
instead you might find three or four
almond butters on thrive but you know
that they are sourced from the best of
the best because they only choose the
best and you'll find supplements protein
powders all the stuff that allows you to
get in shape imagine spending 12 bucks
for Justins almond butter as opposed to
16 bucks right that's that's how thrive
market works for all my listeners my
friends at thrive market are offering
you right now $60 of free groceries plus
free shipping and a 30-day free trial
which is pretty amazing that's
equivalent of tubs of collagen or
digestive enzymes it's the equivalent of
what you would be spending at Whole
Foods on stuff that you'll never use but
you'll be spending it at the rive market
instead all for switching to thrive
market for your online grocery needs
again thrive market they're offering you
60 bucks of free groceries plus free
shipping and a 30 day and 30 day free
trial again their prices are already 25
to 15 percent off retail and now they're
offering 60 bucks of free groceries as
well so it's a terrific deal thrive
market calm / Shapiro never go to Whole
Foods again spend way less money and
union also don't have to deal with the
crowds of weirdos who are cold food so
thrive market calm / Shapiro get your
instant $60 of free groceries so go
ahead and check it out and use / Shapiro
not only for the $60 free groceries but
so they know that we sent you as well
okay so as far as tax reform goes the
Republicans do need to pass tax reform
but not because it's gonna win them any
great credit from the American people
they have to pass it because otherwise
they've literally done nothing this year
and they're a bunch of problems with the
current tax plan that's being tried out
by the Senate Senate Republicans are
already watering this thing down they're
revisiting key provisions in the GOP
House proposal including eliminating
property tax deductions as well as state
income tax deduction so everybody in
California just gets jacked increasing
the size of childcare credits offering
more help to small businesses according
to the LA Times and having corporate tax
cuts phase in or expire according to
those familiar with the negotiation so
in other words this will not be a
massive tax cut it will be a temporary
tax cut with some tax increases all so
that they can say they passed something
I'd rather they pass nothing they passed
a bad bill I haven't seen you know the
final Senate bill but it's not great
okay they're not talking about about
increasing individual tax brackets this
is not what I voted for the Republican
Party for and this is now what I voted
for the Republican Party for but
unfortunately it's all become a game of
which leader do you follow as opposed to
which policy to you espouse I don't see
Trump really espousing low tax policies
in a coherent way I don't see Brian
doing and I don't see any of the
Republicans doing it and that's
incredibly frustrating to me somebody
who actually cares about the policy much
more than I care about the personal in
fighting okay time for some things I
like and then some things I hate and the
big idea so things I like you know well
first we have to go to break first we're
gonna break and we're gonna on Facebook
and YouTube for $9.99 a month you can
get your subscription to daily wired.com
when you do that then you get the rest
of our show live on video you get the
rest of Andrew Clavin show live on video
and Michael Knowles's show live on video
yet all of them for free when you
subscribe for $9.99 a month you also get
to be part of our mailbag there there's
something called the conversation which
is coming next Tuesday with Michael
Knowles at 2 p.m. Pacific and you can
ask questions right we're gonna
broadcast it live on YouTube and
Facebook but you can actually you can
actually check it out and ask questions
you can be one of people asking
questions to Michael God love them over
at our Facebook or daily wire web site
when you subscribe and then log in to
two daily wire in order to ask questions
so check that out if you own an annual
subscription you get all of those things
plus you got this the very greatest and
beverage vessels that I have been
sipping radically all that you leftist
here is hot or cold daily wire tumbler
world-famous
often imitated never duplicated check it
out if you want to listen later for free
go to YouTube or SoundCloud or iTunes
subscribe leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so time for anything I like
so I could not help but but laughs
hysterically yesterday over this so USA
Today ran a video in which they were
explaining what weapon had been used in
the Texas shooting in the Texas church
shooting it was a Ruger AR 556 and here
is I need to show you some of this video
because it's there's some parts of it
that are quite insane this is what we
know about the Ruger AR 556 base model
buttstock rear sight front sight
handguard 30 round magazine trigger okay
so they're teaching you what the parts
of the gun are the ar-15 style rifles
have many aftermarket options some
common some rare this is possible
modifications
100-round drum magazine under barrel
12-gauge shotgun trigger crank chainsaw
bayonet
and this is the composite there this is
the one that got the internet going
chainsaw bayonet hey I don't know anyone
who's ever attached a chainsaw bayonet
to your to your rightful first of all
you set that sucker running it's gonna
throw off your shooting also what when's
the last time you had to chop down a
tree to shoot it a bear like you're in
the middle of the forest you're like ah
shoot okay like what that doesn't make a
whole hell of a lot of sense I mean I
think it's perfect for Gears of War or
or it's great for if you're on The
Walking Dead you need to saw through
somebody's head or something but
chainsaw bayonet so obviously this
spurred a lot of imitators really
ridiculous so people started making
other possible modifications to tell USA
Today about so here are some of them
they're really funny so here is a one
with a miniature ar-15 attachment with
and even a are a smaller ar-15
attachment under the head so it's a
modification of a modification this one
I think is very powerful this of course
is the nuclear weapon bayonet so
underneath the gun you can actually see
there's a nuclear bomb which is I think
very useful this one is a picture of the
USA Today executive editor and it's a
picture of a guy who has a gun that has
pasted on it like a hood ornament and a
jack knife with a knife a fork and a
spoon and a flashlight and keys pretty
amazing I love it this one look
is that Millennials have now ruined guns
- it's a picture of the ar-15 with the
selfie the selfie stick attached is the
modification and then of course the
famous light saber AR modification it
goes underneath the gun very just
spectacular and this of course it was it
was one of my friends put this one
together this is the most deadly
modification that you can put on an air
15 it's the ar-15 with Chuck Norris
modification up top and you just
released the Chuck Norris but really
guys just like don't talk about guns
anymore look if you don't know what
you're talking about please don't talk
about guns and yes it turns out there
are many possible modifications
presumably could put a tank on the
bottom of your air 15 but that does not
actually mean that it's something that
people use and nobody actually USA Today
had to issue a tweak clarifying they
weren't saying a chain gun it chained a
chain saw
gun was used in Texas saying by the way
we're just saying it's a possibility
not that the shooter actually used a
chainsaw bayonet in the church and
thanks for the clarification USA Today
well duh no wonder no one trusts you
when it comes to guns stuff if you
legitimately put out a video that shows
a chainsaw in it
it's the possible modification to an AR
so everyone who's ripping on the AR just
quick note the guy who shot the bad guy
was using an error when he did it okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
thing that I hate today
there's an article from The Guardian hey
you see these kind of articles all the
time Bill Gates Jeff Bezos and Warren
Buffett are wealthier than poorest half
of the United States Institute for
Policy Studies
lefty senator Lorentz made moral crisis
and says Trump tax change proposals will
exacerbate disparities okay I hate this
line of attack I think it's really
stupid the idea that somebody is wealthy
so you are poor is not true if that were
true capitalism would not have made
lives better for the poorest people
around the world radically better okay
half the world has been lifted out of
disparate desperate poverty over the
last thirty years thanks to the rise of
free trade and capitalism this idea that
the economy is a zero-sum game belies
truth it is just not true so what if
Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos and Warren
Buffett are sitting on two hundred fifty
billion dollars of fortune who cares you
know many people work for those people
you know many people are made rich by
those people tons of people an economist
and co-author of the report he says
wealth inequality is on the rise now is
the time for actions that reduce
inequality not tax cuts for the very
wealthy how about more prosperity for
everyone if you want to redistribute all
the income we could do that I suppose by
killing the rich and they're standing
out their money to the poor gets rid of
a lot of the income inequality also it
makes everyone's life a lot worse I hate
this idea that that wealth disparity
means poverty that's just not true if
I'm making $100,000 a year and you're
making a million dollars a year we have
a bigger wealth disparity than if I am
making $10,000 a year in MIT you're
making $5,000 a year right we have a
$900,000 disparity as opposed to a
$5,000 disparity which one would you
prefer if you answered the latter I
would say that you're a bad person
really if you'd say that you prefer to
make $5,000 a year just so I make 10
that shows that you're jealous Punk not
that you actually care about your living
standard okay time for the big idea so
on Thursdays we talk about the big idea
there's a lot of talk this week about
thoughts and prayers and so I thought
that I would talk very briefly about the
problem of theodicy okay so theodicy is
the problem of how can god the
omnipotent and good and yet bad things
happen in the world and it seems like
every time something bad happens in the
world left says how could a good God
allow this this is why I don't believe
in religion as though religion had never
contemplated this question I just might
the fact that every major religious
thinker ever has contemplated this
question but seriously all of them the
idea that God is benevolent and good is
based on the idea that God is purely
actual right that God is the that
everything that exists
is due to God because God is the purely
actual basically in the in the
Aristotelian model anyway the idea here
is it the arista there Aristotle Aquinas
Maimonides model of God basically the
idea here is that everything in life has
the aspects that are either actual or
potential right if you have a candle on
your desk and it's made of wax and you
melt it okay it had the potential to be
a melted pool of wax before but
something actual had to act upon the wax
in order to melt it right a fire had to
act upon the wax which was actual in
order to melt it into a pool of wax I
wasn't in candle form this is true for
all things in the universe according to
Aristotelian thought except for if there
is something that can actualize if
there's something that has no potential
right it just is the purely actual what
it is is actuality right its essence is
the actual well the idea in Aristotle's
notion of good is that what the good is
what mean what makes something good is
that it is it is fitted to its purpose
right so if you are if something is good
that it's fitted to its purpose then God
being purely actual is fitted to God's
purpose because his purpose is the
actuality right God's purpose is him in
other words and so the idea here is that
God is purely actual so this leads to
the question okay so let's say God is
purely good according to WHO standard so
is he good according to human moral
standards so clearly this is something
with which people struggle right in the
Bible Abraham struggles with God
any questions God and he asks why God is
doing certain things and at a certain
point God says you know I can't explain
this to you this is supposedly what
Moses asked God when Moses says show me
your face and God says you can't see my
face and live right the idea there is
that Moses asking why bad things happen
to good people and vice-versa and God is
saying you can't know the answer so the
Jewish answer to theodicy why bad things
happen to good people is twofold one is
with regard to human action and one is
with regard to nature so the answer is
it with what idea human action is it is
not God's responsibility if I decide to
do something terrible today there's my
responsibility the reason God created us
as creative beings is that we have free
will and we can choose to do differently
if that's the case then God by nature
has to restrict his own dominance over
the universe so that I can have free
will and act out freely
that means I'm responsible for my own
evil that's why human evil exists so
that there's the potential for human
goods that we can discover our purpose
and fulfill it right as far as the
notion of other
evils like cancer like a travel cancer
Judaism basically does what a lot of
other religions do and says listen
anyone who presumes to give you an
answer on this is full of it there are
no good answers right you just thought
we don't understand we don't understand
right Maimonides actually says that it's
forbidden to ask those sorts of
questions further to the extent that
there's no good answer to them
Augustine says that evil doesn't really
exist right Augustine's take on evil is
that evil doesn't exist it is just the
absence of good all right the idea being
that if the good is fulfilled potential
then if potential is not entirely
fulfilled that is an evil so it's a
diminishment this so-called privation
theory right it's privation of the good
is what evil is evil doesn't exist as an
independent entity so when you see
somebody who's blind the evil of their
blindness is that it is not a
fulfillment of sight right it's a lack
of something so God limits himself in
the universe so we can have free will
and that allows for lack two to lack of
something to make good into evil
essentially you know there are many many
theories on theodicy but the idea that I
want to promote today is that theodicy
is a serious question with which we
should deal but atheism has no problem
of theodicy I don't even understand how
an atheist can ask about whether God is
good or evil or whether a situation is
good or evil because all that exists in
scientific materialist land is
evolutionary biology there's nothing
good or evil about evolutionary biology
there's just scientific fact so why are
you asking about the moral contents of
things happening in the universe while
you ask about the moral contents of even
human action you're don't ask if a dog
eats if a dog eats as a snail you don't
ask about why the dog eat snail you
don't say why is the dog so evil a moral
component only enter into the picture
when you are talking about the moral
possibilities of the universe
constructed by a God who is bound by the
dictates of his own morality that's the
only time that you even have these
discussions so even asking the theodicy
question is presupposing in orderly
moral universe that you can ask God
about okay so we will be back here
tomorrow with more and the mailbag
hopefully I'll feel a little bit better
and sound less like garbage but we'll
find out if not you'll bear through it
just like I am I mention periods the ben
shapiro show
[Music]